mr. Brad Pitt oh yeah baby what a hottie
he shows up in my dreams I kid you not
and he dominating award fees he
certainly is and tonight his Oscar
evolution it kicks off with Brad the
doting dad
yeah it's just nothing's cool nothing's
cool with dad anymore but this why we do
it you know that's where we do these for
the kids rad off and takes things the
kids make and turns it into something
like he made a blanket one year of all
their drawings 2010 kicked off the
decade of Brangelina
the couple was oh so in love hitting red
carpets together gushing about their
kids Brad even had a sport of canes
after putting his life on the line for
Vivian I was carrying my daughter down a
slope and I slipped and it's me or her
I'm getting really annoyed at the skein
I think I got a couple more days and I'm
gonna wing it
he fights throwing pretends Iza he's not
injured so he's at work you know late
night you go man I'd really like a soda
that's downstairs it doesn't and you go
get it
that's nice 2012 gave us the hashtag
Angie's right leg after drill leaning at
the Oscars it was also the year Brad
popped the question proposing with this
reported 1 million dollar rock in there
six kids were already wedding planning
I've got a lot of crazy ideas and I'm
sure most of them will win out so yes
they'll they'll be the ones deciding to
just you know when it comes and how it's
done and I'm sure three months after
that interview
Brangelina said I do in France Angie
wore a Versace dress the veil included
sketches by their kids
[Music]
a couple skipped a honeymoon to go shoot
their second movie together by the sea
written and directed by Angelina the
drama about a marriage on the rocks was
a far cry from their first film together
mr. and mrs. Smith you know we came out
stronger on the other end just making
something together and something she
wrote it's a real pleasure few weeks
into it we wondered if it was a good
idea because it is quite its it's heavy
and it's a lot of fighting and it's
pretty ugly but film bombed at the box
office making only 3.3 million into Brad
the producer he took a step back from
acting while fighting a bitter custody
battle with Angie by the end of 2016
Brad was sober and got his groove back
how does Brad Pitt relax just friends
family get outside make some things I
feel pretty privileged and and you know
it's there's a shelf life on this thing
hopefully we have other things going for
it
[Music]